die schweiz ein land in dem man gerne
lebt
ein land in dem eigentlich alles
funktioniert viele menschen tragen im
hintergrund dazu bei
mit rené lenzin leitet ein asyl
empfangszentrum rolf bischof berger ist
marktfahrer claudia imhof ist
lokführerin bei den sbb
und kazinakis ist gastwirt wie leben
diese menschen wo versetzen sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt sie vier menschen
und ihr alltag ein tag im leben der
schweiz im juli morgens um drei
in dieser backstube im appenzeller land
herrscht hochbetrieb
in neuenhof in der nähe von baden macht
sich claudia für ihre frühschicht bereit
groll von judith arbeiten auf ihrem
biohof schon seit 26 jahren zusammen
wir sind training absolvieren der
versuchsaufbau möglich macht und den den
graz
die 22 jährige claudia fängt mit ihrer
karriere erst an
die ruhe vor dem sturm bedroht ab
anlocken
8 millionen menschen leben in der
schweiz vreni wird bald pensioniert
noch führt sie das asylzentrum in basel
jeder tag ist anders jedes leben
verschieben
es ist 5 rolf geht einmal in der woche
auf den markt
judith hat die ganze nacht brot gebacken
wie schafft sie das bahnhof brugg um die
gleiche zeit
claudia ist die jüngste lokführerin bei
den sbb
er ist sicher richtig prüft die gräfin
maria dem orgateam umfunktionieren
das wandern das anders da richtig
funktionieren um 50 7 geht's los
die
in st gallen ist ein mal in der woche
markt nur für die bauern aus der region
händler sind nicht zugelassen
konsumenten deftigen unglücklich der
staat will eine ganze sind mit den
produkten der zum teil anbietet und den
können
marc farbe zu achten unter solchen
verstanden hat läuft kann direkt
verkaufen was judith und er auf dem
biohof produziert neben dem brot auch
schaaf fleisch wurst käse eier tomaten
und bären
es ist halb sieben
das asyl empfangszentrum in basel ist
voll belegt 400 menschen sind im moment
hier untergebracht vorwiegend eritrea
und schüler
es ist eines von fünf empfangszentren in
der schweiz trainer arbeitet seit 20
jahren hier
seit 14 jahren ist sie chefin jetzt dazu
hatte sich beschwert sich nicht nur
hoffen dass die neuankömmlinge müssen
sofort in die medizinische kontrolle
weniger strikt 32 reise zu sich sparen
wenn man urlaub einmal an sandro ich
viel weniger schräg drauf wenn sein idol
ihnen sind roma der krise praktisch nie
was sie später
claudia fährt die s 12 eine typische
pendlerstrecke rund 400.000 menschen
steigen jeden tag im zürcher
hauptbahnhof ein und aus
wir wünschen
die schweiz gilt als seriös und
effizient das hat auch seine kehrseite
die klinik
lachen
hier und da erlaubte sich darum einen
kleinen spaß
dem anderer stelle genau die türen sind
im berner schwarz burgenland es ist 8
der landgasthof stehen in obermoschel
hier wird das ehepaar kies aus sri lanka
sinatra käthes kam vor 28 jahren als
flüchtling in die schweiz
vor vier jahren hatte den sternen
übernommen
um schlag
den ersten richtigen kaffee am morgen
bekommt sein stammgast gratis das am
bauernmarkt in st
rolf hat mitgeholfen ihn aufzubauen bis
zu 20 jahren präsident
es ist noch gar nicht so gern organist
dieter winter 0 1 wenn ihr ziel klient
war schweiz fördersystem hat dem
wahnsinnig solche berichte funktioniert
der trick super und kommunen oder simple
zu engagieren
da sollten sie nachrücken haltung und
das material fähig machen
er ist die ansprechperson für alle rolf
hat sich auch elf jahre lang aktiv in
der politik engagiert bis 2010 saß als
grossrats im erotischen kantonsparlament
weniger ums geld bücher schweizer
parteien mal mehr meiste geld und
meister plakat kam lüthi erheblich mehr
erfolg und beispiels ganz sicher nicht
etwa 1 2 millionen menschen benutzten
jeden tag die spd viel druck wenn man
vorne in der führerkabine sitzt
ich bin 1 22 und vorne sehr große
verantwortung
dieses ziel bringt
8500 personenzüge verkehren täglich auf
dem schweizer schienennetz unter
taktfahrplan wird immer enger
halb neun in basel 25 tage bleiben die
flüchtlinge durchschnittlich hier bevor
sie in die kantone geschickt werden
müssen sie ihre bettwäsche abgeben
was hast du eine größere chance für
kinder seine frau am schloss das gibt
stadt gibt's nicht dass ich mal gehabt
habe
ich muss jetzt im moment warten bis für
die themen geburtstagen abgeschrieben
haben muss platz hat dann schaue ich was
hast du gemacht
das sind schmerztabletten für die kleine
am mittag ist es da mit holen das heute
morgen ist einer der klinik sich zu
hause aber tut es nicht zu dem schiff
machen
ich weiß noch nicht wo angefangen habe
entscheidend hatte ganze nacht problem
und das kostet ja als ihre familie als
spiel gehört im empfangszentrum dort hat
es familienzimmer
auch kasseler tanzgeschichte in der
schweiz hat in einem empfangszentrum
begonnen
das einmal gastwirt würde im berner
schwarz boden land hätte er sich nie
träumen lassen
er war gerade 19 jahre alt und wollte in
ziegelanger an die uni gehen als zwei
seiner brüder ermordet wurden
daraufhin haben in seiner eltern in die
schweiz geschickt
das sowie tommy lee bienemann lena
niehues axel junker aus edesheim xii
plötzlich muss er das 2 1 aus
das forum ein
das derzeit in der schweiz hat er sein
schicksal selbst in die hand genommen
und sich vom tellerwäscher zum krach und
dann zum wird hochgearbeitet
es ist 9 claudia ist seit vier stunden
unterwegs
ihr job ist immer noch ein typischer
männerberuf doch am stützpunkt druck
gibt es immerhin zehn frauen gibt es
widerstand
die moral der job des vereins haben das
ist das eigentlich gern in der senior
acht stunden von tag und nacht
mir macht das eigentlich nicht ich bin
jetzt niveau der ganztag betrachtung
rede
halbzeit auch in st gallen
aber ohne pause dafür gibt's kaffee vom
chef rolf verbreitet stets gute laune
die meisten kunden kaufen regelmäßig das
brot ist schon fast ausverkauft
der zweite trainer ist das bio eier
fleisch und würste vor zehn jahren hat
rolf von kühen auf milchschafe
umgestellt
die bereits kontakte umstellen will
zuvor mit friesisches jahr total im
keller und der schauspiel freestyle
schimmerwald der schimmel gleich suppe
und erhält den besseren goalie
persönlich soll mitfliegen mit schaaf
bald mit der sternen in oberburg
schließt gut besucht von ausflüglern und
von stammgästen cassina tann führt im
landgasthof mit seiner frau nannte ihre
beiden kinder regina und renault john
sind in der schweiz zur welt gekommen
dass wirte ehepaar beschäftigt vier
aushilfen drei familien und einen
tunesier als sie vor vier jahren
angefangen haben hatten sie mit vielen
vorurteilen zu kämpfen
damit formiert argument dass es gut ist
kaufe ich eindringe
das ist die sache erledigt das ist total
zur anpassung heißt sein zauberwort das
muss man
so ist es ihnen gelungen das eis zu
brechen aber es hat von zeit gebraucht
er wohnt und arbeitet schon über 20
jahre in dieser gegend im
empfangszentrum in basel 85 prozent hier
sind junge er riet er
wer will kann ein bisschen geld
verdienen vreni hat sich alles mögliche
einfallen lassen um die leute zu
beschäftigen
zu jedem auf friedhöfen bauen waldwege
trennen abfall und bekommen vier franken
25 pro stunde arbeit ausgeschrieben
positive reaktionen auf oder bevölkerung
natürlich gibt es ist positiv dass sie
eigens auf politische diskussionen mag
sich für ihn nicht einlassen
aber sie gibt zu bedenken natürlich
stand jetzt auch oben kurz die kriege
dreimal wohl zieht
sie können aber sie sind ganz weit weg
von daheim
also nicht einfach los luther reise erst
nach sechs stunden steigt claudia auf
den alten domino pendelzug rum und
fertig strecke druck langenthal
mein berater mir
sid
größtes berufsrisiko für lokführer ist
dass sich jemand vor den zug wirft wie
geht claudia damit um dass ihr das auch
irgendwann passieren könnte und ich
glaube das ist eine gute sicht fehlen
mit zu negatives auch fehlt sind 1000
überwiegend und wo man teil vergrössern
und seiner klasse es ist mittagszeit im
sternen
das restaurant ist voll besetzt nantes
anderen organ war schon auf der welt als
kassie nathan mit seiner kochlehre
begann damit das geld reichte arbeitete
er nebenbei noch in einer reinigung
quasi nathan wollte leider und sein chef
hat ihm sehr geholfen
er hat ihm auch alle schweizer rezepte
beigebracht viele der knapp 50.000
familien in der schweiz arbeiten im
gastgewerbe cassina tann hat das wird
patent und die meisterprüfung gemacht
nun darf er selbst lehrlinge ausbilden
und sein wissen weitergeben
auch in basel gibt es mittagessen
wer registriert ist kann mit seiner
karte kommen und gehen wie er will
die meisten sind aber pünktlich zum
mittagessen zurück
drei mahlzeiten täglich gibt es hier
sonst
aber dann kommen
statt
okay okay sie viel zu nass zu stellen
und ganz in connecticut und ich mache
nur aktien im saal
400 menüs werden heute mittag ausgegeben
es tut mir leid ich kann das nicht dass
ihn alle menschen gleich
vreni hat neuigkeiten für die syrische
familie und wenn ich nun fertig wenn
zehn berufen dass alle sie rufen pocket
herrschaft versicherten falschen und
transfers spiel gewonnen haben sie ein
eigenes thema für die familie
es ist 2 golf ist zurück auf seinem hof
im appenzellerland seine tochter leandra
ist zu besuch
die familie ist selten mehr vollständig
leandra geht in kreuzlingen ans
gymnasium und der bruder lukas
studierten zürich es sieht nicht so aus
wie wenn die jungen den hof übernehmen
würden
es ist wichtig dass sich das leben
selber konnte nichts lernen was ist das
nur eine frage macht mir immer seite die
zwischen der biersparte über spuren
fertig wir haben eine große bereit und
mehr pole ab 20 uhr
auch die katys wohnen gerne auf dem land
die kinder gehen in bern zur schule und
haben an den schweizer pass die eltern
mittlerweile die c bewilligung
nach sri lanka gehen sie nur noch in die
ferien auch seine frau nannte hat sich
arrangiert
vor 16 jahren hat sie quasi nathan von
deutschland in die schweiz geholt
die beiden kannten sich schon als kinder
ist eingetroffen
weil hier raus hier
läuft muss noch das feuer holen
dass sein hof so gut läuft ist nicht
selbstverständlich ein schädel hirn
trauma nach einem traktorunfall hätte
sein leben um ein haar total verändert
die b14 wickelt oomoxx und oder
behindert sein können
rolf bewirtschaftet 30 hektaren auf
verschiedensten kleinen parzellen in
dieser hügeligen landschaft
ist das nicht sehr anstrengend
mit den fetzigen beats und bulimie
wir wünschen und will jetzt mehr
möglichkeiten zum erreichen muss mit dem
leben
und was sagt und fährt davon
um sich um die schafe zu kümmern
auch in basel versucht vreni das beste
aus der situation zu machen
sie hat den außenraum überdacht und
immer am nachmittag bietet sie
deutschkurs an
die arbeit hier bringt manchmal ins
grüne zu fahren oder zumindest zu
beschäftigen
es ist 4
claudia hat mit ihrer älteren schwester
abgemacht die beiden sehen sich häufig
sie sind mit ihrer mutter allein
aufgewachsen
der vater hat die familie verlassen als
claudia zwei jahre alt war
tanja lebte in einem heim für behinderte
sie hat ein down-syndrom der behinderten
verein macht einen ausflug schlau der
begleitet anja und engagiert sich auch
aktiv im verein als behinderung hat
claudias leben geprägt
zur diskussion über die früherkennung
von behinderungen in der schwangerschaft
hat sie eine klare meinung
ich höre eigentlich nie mit estella im
bus und machen
euro
die stars
schön
diesen schreber geraten hat vreni von
ihren eltern übernommen
niki ihr partner ist auch gerne hier
seit 20 jahren sind die beiden ein paar
trainings sohn claudio ist ebenfalls
gekommen
womöglich trifft man sich am abend mit
freunden zum jassen ausgespäht habe gar
nicht durch die kv dem rapper aber mit
mir spiel das egal was ich spiele mit
weil events entspannen sie spielt toll
dass jede versicherung wir dem handy
spielt oder und fahren sie ein
statisches opitz geselligkeit
das finde ich toll und der bei mir
spieler für uns
das ist unsere serie mit diesem im
oktober drei wochen und können mit dem
unterricht die woche getränk nachlassen
oder soziale und sich eigentlich von des
geld und macht spaß bald kann sie noch
ausgiebiger reisen wird pensioniert
machen spaß
claudia steht ganz woanders leben erst
vor drei monaten ist sie mit ihrem
freund silvio zusammengezogen alles ist
noch ein bisschen neu
ihre beste freundin ist zu besuch
seelow ist auch lokführer irgendwann
wollen sie eine familie gründen
aber die rollenverteilung ist noch nicht
ausgehandelt
und treffen bin
charlie
rolf hat 300 schafe die scharf milch ist
eine wichtige einkommensquelle ohne
direktzahlungen würde es aber schwer mit
all den sachen die sie produzieren und
dem direktverkauf auf dem markt haben
sie jedoch die möglichkeit immer wieder
neues auszuprobieren
interessant und trainings tochter
sabrina schaut auch vorbei wenn's geht
ich begann mich sepideh heicks also
nicht bösartig intercell fahrzeuge nicht
einfach der hayek und der stellte worden
sind habe ich mit einem alten film wird
für betrieb sechs von zehn frauen sind
heute berufstätig in der schweiz
vreni und der mann hatten sich
auseinandergelebt
aber sie hat lange gewartet bis sie sich
getrennt hat sich mini zum nassen
schritt bewegen allein auf der kinder
nicht wenn die buche platz von yapi und
sieht den achsen von sony steht melanie
franke 20 jahre funktioniert die
patchworkfamilie schon so
mackie und vreni haben sich in einer
kuppe kennengelernt
in trance
das heißt nichts zusammen seiner hobbys
familie hobbys aber trocken hauptgründe
reise früh geschafft
das harmoniert wir können halt seltsamen
gegenstand seiner doch es geht einmal
kraft doch wieder der alltag sieht das
im job oder sonst finde dass ich
wahnsinnig wichtig dass westliche / oder
als friedensliebe und ich darf kaputt
sagen ich hab's ja mitten im schönen
schweizer
auch neuenhof wird der grill angeworfen
durchschnittlich 41 mal im jahr rücken
der schweiz trainiert das ist was
dreimal mehr als bei den nachbarn in
deutschland und in drei viertel der
haushalte sind die männer fürs
grillieren zuständig jährlich werden 52
kilo fleisch pro kopf vertilgt auch wenn
in der schweiz bereits 80.000 menschen
veganer sind
wir sehen kriegen
berufen
auch rolle von judith essen er scharf
fleisch am liebsten gegrillt oft gibt
dazu kaffee komplett mit dem was der hof
her kennt
beide kommen aus bauernfamilien und
haben sich früh kennengelernt
schon seit 26 jahren sind sie ein team
und arbeiten ohne personal haben sie
nicht stimmt ist der partnerschaft im
gespräch bleiben finden sie beide
wichtig nicht nur für sich sondern auch
für die gesellschaft
judith hat gar nicht geschlafen und rolf
crm letzten acht
zeit ins bett zu gehen
wer kassiert angehört der stammtisch zum
abitur er hat es geschafft das in seinem
restaurant der jodlerklub und seine
landsleute regelmäßig ins gespräch
kommen
premiere
und vreni sie findet miteinander im
gespräch bleiben auch wichtig aber sie
hätte noch ein anderes anliegen für die
schweiz
egal schlägt sony zu russland russland
läuft mit toleranz im nacken gegenüber
weil man erkennt die schlafen und morgen
stehen sie wieder auf und mit ihnen acht
millionen andere menschen in der schweiz
jeder mit seinem alltag und mit seiner
geschichte
nächste woche maria cardoso sorgt für
saubere straßen in zürich justin kurvt
mit dem postauto durch die berge
regula fankhauser rettet menschen in not
und tcs man maße blue hilft wenn das
auto streikt